The question of leadership is really
interesting because,
uh,
for,
for most businesses really at this
point,
the loss of control they fear is already
in the past,
right?
That,
that there was,
there was a media environment in which
almost any message about ibm that was in
the public was created by IBM and then
circulated via press release or reported
by a newspaper or what have you.
Uh,
and then of course there was a,
you know,
word of mouth chatter on the street
kinds of stuff,
but that all operated at a level so much
smaller than anything a large company
can produce.
Uh,
the biggest change in leadership I think
is that those days are over.
And uh,
there's the range of choices leaders
have about the perception of their
company a has been quite,
quite restricted,
uh,
because the counter story will always
get at as well.
And it's just,
it's just much more of a dialogue in the
public.
So,
so the two great visions of,
of leadership we have,
right,
the grand visionary or the micromanager,
uh,
now seem to meet not to work as well.
Uh,
the,
the Internet is kind of compressed,
the range and leadership has become
instead a combination of a,
infusing a company with whatever the
core,
the core imperatives are,
and making sure that the company doesn't
overbalance too far in one direction or
another.
So Amazon,
to take just one example,
Amazon has my favorite corporate award
ever in the history of corporate awards.
They have an award that you can only win
as an employee if you do something great
and you didn't ask permission first,
right?
In other words,
you can get if you ask permission,
if you clear things with your bosses,
but if you do something really good and
you just saw that it was a possibility
and you did it,
you've got a special word for not having
asked permission.
And that's an example of something that
to your friend,
your earlier point about your friend
lowers the amount of internal
communication required and also sets a
cultural norm for the business that no
amount of memos and mission statements
could Sibley send.
And that kind of leadership.
What,
what,
what visa does.
I think in terms of creating a cultural
climate where good ideas are rewarded
matters so much more than,
you know,
either grand visioning or a micromanager
in this,
in this environment.